right now that brand new apple studio
display behind me is nothing more than a
dust collector let me explain what's
going on guys welcome back to the
channel for those of you who don't know
me my name is david tomic and i'm a
registered architect here in western
australia a couple days ago i received
that brand new apple studio display
behind me and boy was i excited to open
it up
now i'll preface this with i've ordered
a brand new mac studio as well the m1
ultra chip which hasn't arrived yet i
ordered them both at the same time
that one arrived in three weeks the mac
studio isn't due for at least another
six weeks so i thought you but let's
open this bad boy up put it on the desk
and start using it with my windows pc
all sorts of reviews on the internet
have said yes you can absolutely use it
with your pc so i didn't really look
into it too much further and that
probably should be the biggest red flag
for me
because i should have known to dive deep
into every tech product before i get
excited about it now if you're running a
windows pc and you have a brand new
studio display in mind you better make
sure that your pc has some sort of
thunderbolt 3 or thunderbolt 4
compatible port in the system
because if it doesn't you're going to
have the same problem as i do right now
it's literally black it's literally
blank it will not function it doesn't
matter what kind of workaround you're
trying to figure out be it a hdmi cable
into a thunderbolt adapter directly into
the back usbc to displayport doesn't
work direct hdmi to usbc cable doesn't
work now you may be thinking maybe this
display doesn't work maybe you should
really test it out before you make this
video
i actually did that before i got too
disheartened about the whole thing
because that display there works
perfectly with the brand new 24-inch
imac behind me as a secondary display
and boy is it good the brand new studio
display is actually incredible it is
crisp it is clear and i'm extremely
excited to use it with a studio display
when it does arrive and i will do a full
unboxing and full review of that when
the time comes when it arrives
and for the time being i'm literally
just gonna have to push it to the side
and hope for the best if you by any
chance know of any workaround that i
haven't tried that the internet hasn't
figured out yet
well please leave a comment down below
because currently my eight-year-old
custom-built gaming tower down there
running a hdmi cord directly from the
graphics card up into a thunderbolt
adapter does not work and that is the
closest thing i'm going to get to a
thunderbolt port in any way shape or
form because there's no chance i'm
upgrading that desktop with a brand new
mac studio arriving in a couple of weeks
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i really
just wanted to share with you that if
you don't have a pc without a
thunderbolt port in the back anywhere
then don't worry about buying the studio
display because it won't work